well I think that there is a drive in
human beings and perhaps and some of our
ancestor are a band sisters as well but
particular there's something that
happens with human beings where they
there is a kind of dissatisfaction where
it could be as simple as a tool that
doesn't work very well and you modify it
so it works better there is a sort of a
drive to make incremental improvements
and it could be you know you really hate
the way your parents behave toward you
so when you have kids you're going to do
it a different way and maybe it's better
maybe it's worse and your kids then do
it a different way and and it can be as
simple as modifying recipes it could be
as big as you know writing the US
Constitution and sort of creating a new
country and there's a learning process
that takes place with that and and a lot
of them learning and this is one of the
messages in the future and its enemies
is very incremental it's it's a lot of
modest changes and experiments that add
up over time to major progress and you
don't necessarily know where you're
headed there's a there's a writer named
Henry Petrovsky he's a civil engineering
professor at Duke and he writes about
the evolution of technical things of
objects and artifacts and he has this
great phrase form follows failure which
is of course a play on form follows
function and his ideas when you have an
artifact as soon as it exists you find
the things that you don't like about it
and the existence of the initial
artifact allows you to innovate and say
oh well this is how we'd like to improve
it and I think that's a process that
does far beyond artifacts it is how we
get technological improvements but it's
not the only way um so that's that that
accounts that doesn't account for
everything of you know how we built all
these but that's a lot of it I think
there is a power of individuals
when they are interact a lot together
there's an idea of sort of an idea that
I took from Daniel Boorstin see as you
can see I'm big synthesizer everything
everything has a footnote from somebody
else called verges which is the idea of
different things coming together so it
could be different ethnic groups trading
different different different
geographical regions coming together you
had this notion that that's where a lot
of creativity takes place and I think
that a lot of the creative power of
cities over the centuries has come from
that sort of it being a place where
people of some kind of difference
interact in a positive use more in a
positive way and trade is a lot of that
various forms of learning or a lot of
that even things like missionary expert
efforts can take place there and that
you know there's positives and negatives
but that's ultimately where you come
from this sort of exchange is where a
lot of the sort of progress and growth
and development of civilizations come
from and then there's things you just go
like how could that happen it's so
amazing you know there are bad things
that happen to go how to get that happen
to but even on the positive side you
know how is it I've been raining a lot
about Renaissance Florence how did that
happen you know what what is it and
historians puzzle over this you know how
do you have this flourishing of art in
certain places or of science in certain
places what was it about you know Vienna
in the early 20th century or buda-pesht
that allowed these great minds to cross
fertilize each other in these such
interesting ways or London and Edinburgh
in the night 18th century what happened
there you know what words the fan what
was going on with the founding fathers
what is that they seem like a remarkable
group of people it has something to do
with interaction the whole is the parts
are great but the holes even somehow
greater than the sum of the parts and
these aren't I think in some sense
historical mysteries but really worthy
of thinking about and study because they
go beyond the simple incremental ISM of
saying there could be progress even if
it's very modest efforts of you know
making better toothpaste or what
Oh